ونحن هنا في مطار أنطونوف
الذي يبعد حوالي 25 كيلومترًا و 15 ميلًا أو
نحو ذلك عن المركز ، فهذه القوات التي
يمكنك رؤيتها هنا تقف واقفًا ،
فهذه القوات التي يمكنك رؤيتها هنا
هي القوات الروسية المحمولة جواً التي
استولوا عليها في هذا المطار.  لقد سمح لنا
بالدخول وأن نكون معهم وهم يدافعون
عن محيط هذه القاعدة الجوية هنا
حيث
هبطت هذه القوات التي تحمل طائرات الهليكوبتر
في الساعات الأولى من
صباح اليوم لأخذ وتشكيل جسر جوي
للسماح لمزيد من القوات
تعال ويمكنك أن ترى أن هذه هي القوة الروسية ،
يمكنك أن تخبرهم بأنهم روس ، لقد
تحدثت إليهم بالفعل ، يمكنك أن تخبرهم
أنهم روس لديهم ذلك
الشريط البرتقالي والأسود لتحديدهم كقوات روسية
تحدثت إليهم  القائد
على الأرض هناك في غضون الدقائق القليلة الماضية
وقال إنهم الآن
يسيطرون
على هذا المطار وخلال الثواني القليلة الماضية
قبل مجيئكم إلينا
، انخرطوا في معركة بالأسلحة النارية على
الأرجح مع الجيش الأوكراني
الذي يقول  نحن نشن
هجومًا مضادًا لمحاولة استعادة
هذا المطار هذا يمكننا إخبارك
الآن أنني أقف خارج
محيط قاعدة أنطونوف الجوية هذه
ولم يتم استعادتها من قبل الجيش الأوكراني ،
إنه الجيش الروسي  يمكنك
أن تراهم الآن يعودون
إلى موقع مختلف ، وهو الجيش الأوكراني
الذي يقول إنهم الآن في موقع السيطرة.
إلى أي مدى اقتربت القوات الروسية
من وسط العاصمة الأوكرانية
، لم يكن الأمر كذلك ، لقد ذهبت إلى
المسؤولين في وقت سابق مع المسؤولين الأوكرانيين
وهم يقولون
إن الخطة ليست فقط لتطويق
العاصمة الأوكرانية ، فهم يخشون الآن أن
الخطة هي  خذ رأس المال
لقطع رأس القيادة في أوكرانيا
واستبدال تلك القيادة
بحكومة موالية لروسيا ، وهذا ما
يقوله لنا المسؤولون الأوكرانيون الآن
يعتقدون أنها الخطة الروسية يمكنني أن
أخبركم أنها متوفرة.  موقف متوتر للغاية
نتوقع أن نشهد
خوض الجيش الأوكراني ، لم نكن نعرف حتى
بصراحة ، لم نكن نعرف حتى أنك
تعلم أن القوات الروسية ستكون
هنا ، لقد افترضنا أن هذه كانت القوات الأوكرانية
التي صعدت إليها للتحدث معهم  أقول
مرحبًا ، لقد جئنا من كييف كما تعلم ، لكن
ظهر فقط خلال المحادثة
أنهم جميعًا روس ولا
توجد قوات عسكرية أوكرانية في الأفق
رغم أنني أستطيع سماعهم آه
لأنهم كانوا يطلقون النار بشراسة في
نبض الماضي القليل  دقائق ولذا
فنحن نوعًا ما في موقع دفاعي
خلف هذا الجدار هنا لديك سيارتنا
هنا مع الطاقم هنا أيضًا
كما تعلمون ، حيث تدافع القوات الروسية المحمولة جواً
عن هذا الموقف الذي
اتخذوه في ضواحي كييف